Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
J'espère que vous êtes en forme
parce qu'aujourd'hui
je vous emmène à la montagne.
Non, non, je ne vous fais pas marcher.
On va vraiment faire de la randonnée,
on va grimper tout là haut, au Col
de Cou, juste le temps de remplir ma gourde.
Hop !
Mais avant de partir, une petite vérification.
Quand on part marcher en montagne,
il faut prendre un coupe-vent
ou un vêtement de pluie.
À la montagne, le temps change très vite.
Une trousse de premiers secours
pour soigner les petits bobos,
de la crème solaire.
Car là haut, ça tape très fort.
De quoi refaire le plein d'énergie,
des barres de céréales ou des fruits secs.
Une lampe de poche car on peut être
surpris par la nuit et enfin de l'eau.
Au moins un litre par personne.
Voilà, vous êtes prêts ?
Alors c'est parti !
On va là haut !
Ce qui est bien à la montagne, c'est
qu'en grimpant, on croise des espèces
qu'on ne rencontre pas ailleurs.
Des végétaux et des animaux qui sont
capables de résister à l'altitude.
Bonjour !
Bonjour ! Et également
aux écarts de température.
Froid l'hiver, chaud l'été.
On appelle ça l'amplitude thermique.
Et les rois de ce paysage ?
Ils sont autour de moi.
Ce sont les sapins, mais aussi
les épicéas comme celui-ci.
Autrement dit, les conifères.
Tiens au fait,
vous savez pourquoi on les a baptisés
conifères ?
C'est à cause de leurs fruits en forme
de cône comme la fameuse pomme de pin.
Il y en a plein autour de moi.
On dit aussi très souvent résineux.
Je vais vous montrer pourquoi.
Quand un conifère est blessé,
comme ici, il sécrète une sorte de liquide visqueux, poisseux.
Attention, ce n'est pas de la sève, c'est
la fameuse résine, une substance
qui va protéger l'arbre contre les parasites,
les mauvaises bactéries et les champignons.
Ça colle aux doigts... bwah !
L'autre caractéristique des conifères,
ce sont leurs feuilles, ou plutôt leurs aiguilles.
Elles se renouvellent en permanence,
ce qui permet
à l'arbre de rester vert pendant toute l'année.
Y compris pendant l'hiver.
Et grâce à ces aiguilles, l'arbre peut
également résister au froid et au gel.
On va faire une petite expérience.
En fait, les feuillus, comme cet érable,
perdent leurs feuilles en automne
pour éviter de trop grandes pertes
d'eau en transpirant pendant l'hiver. De l'eau
qu'ils ne pourraient pas renouveler
étant donné qu'en hiver,
le sol est très souvent gelé.
J'ai bien dit que l'arbre transpirait. Il respire et il transpire.
Et vous pouvez le constater
chez vous ou à l'école, en faisant cette petite expérience.
Il y a une petite demi heure j’ai emmailloté cette branche
dans un sac en plastique que j'ai refermé hermétiquement.
Et regardez bien ce qu'il se passe
maintenant.
Le sac est plein de buée.
Il y a même des petites gouttelettes
d'eau.
Preuve donc que les feuilles de cet arbre transpirent.
C'est pour cette raison qu'à l'automne,
l'érable va perdre ses feuilles
pour économiser de l'eau. De l'eau
qu'il ne pourrait pas puiser dans le sol
puisque très souvent, je l'ai dit, il est gelé.
Par ailleurs, en hiver, à cause du froid,
la feuille qui est pleine d'eau, dont les cellules sont gorgées
d'eau, gèlerait. Les cellules éclateraient
et la feuille mourrait.
Donc les feuillus préfèrent
perdre leurs feuilles à l'automne.
Les conifères ne connaissent pas
ce genre de problème.
D'abord, parce que les aiguilles sont toutes fines
et que la surface de contact avec le froid est très étroite.
Ensuite,
quand on observe ces aiguilles de très près, on constate qu'elles sont recouvertes
d'une couche cireuse, une couche qui brille sous la lumière.
Cette couche ralentit la transpiration.
Enfin, étant donné qu'elles sont très étroites,
la neige ne peut pas s'y accumuler
pendant l'hiver et briser les branches.
Pour toutes ces raisons, la plupart des conifères
peuvent garder leurs aiguilles pendant toute l'année, y compris en hiver.
La plupart ! Il y a toujours des exceptions, le mélèze qui, lui, perd ses aiguilles
au début de l'automne, tout simplement parce que ses aiguilles
ne sont pas recouvertes de cette petite couche cireuse.
Vous voyez, les habitations en bas,
ça fait déjà une belle trotte.
Alors marcher,
a priori, ça semble très simple et pourtant,
si l'on n'y prend pas garde, on peut très vite s'essouffler.
Quelques petits conseils, marchez à votre rythme
le plus régulier possible. Evitez
d'accélérer ou de ralentir.
Tiens, un petit truc si vous êtes en groupe,
tant que vous pouvez parler à haute
voix, c'est que tout va bien.
Pensez aussi à
faire des pauses régulières
pour vous réhydrater.
En plus, quand on retire son sac,
ça soulage le dos et les épaules.
Il faut aussi profiter du paysage.
En plus, ici, on voit très bien
les différents environnements
que l'on peut croiser en montagne,
les différents milieux.
Ici, on parle d'étage.
En bas, il y a la vallée avec les villages
et les champs.
Juste au dessus, la forêt de conifères
qu'on vient de quitter.
Encore quelques marches et ce sont les alpages où nous sommes.
On croise des troupeaux et puis encore plus haut,
l'étage nival ou il n'y a quasiment plus de végétation.
Là où à partir d'une certaine altitude,
il y a les neiges éternelles.
C'est très, très beau.
Bon faut peut-être pas trainer parce qu'on a rendez-vous avec les marmottes.
Allez, c'est reparti !
Et je pénètre dans l'étage
alpin, plus précisément
ce que l'on appelle la zone de combat.
Ici, les végétaux livrent leurs derniers combats
face aux éléments, le vent et le froid.
Les arbres sont beaucoup moins grands et la végétation pousse au ras du sol.
Ah j'aperçois Jean-Paul, notre guide.
C'est lui qui a l'adresse des marmottes
et qui connaît aussi très bien
la flore de ces alpages.
Bonjour Jean-Paul !
Qu'est-ce que tu prends en photo ?
Petits parterres de crépides dorées,
fleurs
typiquement qu'on trouve en montagne.
Celle-ci ? Celle-ci tu vois.
On va aller vers la petite gentiane
qui est là. Tu vois, gentiane de couleur pourpre, donc beaucoup plus petite que la grande
gentiane jaune avec laquelle on fait
des alcools. Là, la gentiane ponctuée.
Et si on regarde un petit peu plus haut,
regarde, on a une campanule un peu spéciale.
Ah oui, des petits poils aux extrémités des pétales.
On la prénomme la campanule barbue,
tout simplement.
Et en contrebas, regarde Jamy, des toutes petites fleurs
tellement petites, elles nous cassent les lunettes Jamy.
On l'appelle l'euphraise casse-lunettes et regarde Jamy.
Ici, la brunelle. Alors ici, à la montagne, évidemment,
on regarde les plantes et on ne les cueille pas.
On les laisse dans leur milieu naturel.
Là, on a sous nos yeux un insecte qui est
en train de butiner. Comme on est en altitude,
il y a moins d'insectes que dans la vallée.
Et donc, pour les attirer, les plantes
se sont habillées de jolies couleurs.
Tiens, Jamy regarde au dessus de nous là.
Est-ce que tu connais ?
Euh, non.
Arnica. Alors,
ça, oui, j'en ai dans mon armoire
à pharmacie. Sûrement, certainement.
Tu vois donc, c'est avec ce genre de fleurs qu'on fait donc les fameuses pommades
d'arnica contre les coups.
Qu'est-ce qu'on utilise ?
La feuille et la fleur.
- Eh ben... ça fait mal.
Ça fait mal.
Alors on a souvent le sentiment que
la montagne n'est qu'un espace de loisirs.
Or, il s'y pratique tout un tas d'autres activités économiques.
L'exploitation du bois, bien sûr, et puis
l'élevage.
D'ailleurs, nous avons devant nous
un petit groupe de vaches.
Elle nous a vu venir.
Le petit conseil qu'on peut donner, c'est
qu'étant donné que les vaches
ont les yeux sur les côtés quand on s'en approche, c'est d'éviter
de leur faire face pour les surprendre
et plutôt de les approcher par le flanc.
L'autre petit conseil qu'on peut donner
si une vache est avec son veau,
il faut toujours éviter de s'intercaler
entre le petit et la mère.
Exactement. Elles ont de jolies cloches,
comment on appelle ça ?
Alors la cloche qu'on voit là, qui a un son quand même de casseroles.
Ça s'appelle le potet.
Et l'autre style de cloche qu'on peut voir dans les alpages,
la cloche, avec la forme de cloche qui est souvent gravée en laiton.
Qui a un son beaucoup plus fin.
On l'appelle donc la clarine. La clarine. Au tout départ,
on leur met des cloches pour les repérer
dans l'alpage, qui est vaste ici,
qui est très vaste
comme tu peux le voir. Pour savoir ou elles sont.
C'est vrai que tout à l'heure,
on entendait les cloches, mais on ne les voyait pas forcément.
Et en plus, il faut imaginer aussi que
de temps en temps ici, il y a du brouillard.
Qu'est-ce qu'on rencontre comme race ici ? Alors,
on rencontre particulièrement ici
donc la race abondance,
qui est particulière, justement avec sa robe marron,
marron foncé et ses yeux,
ses yeux entourés de marron.
Et on appelle ceci donc les lunettes
de l'abondance qui protègent
comme une paire de lunettes du soleil
par rapport à sa tête bien blanche.
Donc moins de réverbération et l'autre
race qu'on peut voir dans nos secteurs là.
C'est la race tarine. La tarine
qui est plus claire, donc que l'abondance.
Elle a même
la tête toute
marron clair et des yeux magnifiques
en forme d'amande.
On a vraiment l'impression
qu'elles se maquillent les yeux.
Elle est charmante. Elle est charmante cette petite vache tarine.
Avec leur lait, on fabrique plusieurs fromages.
L'abondance bien sûr.
Le beaufort avec le lait de la tarine
et tomme de montagne.
Alors si on trouve ces vaches
dans les alpages, ce n'est pas par hasard.
Elles sont parfaitement adaptées
au relief.
D'abord, elles ne sont pas très hautes,
elles sont très agiles aussi,
ce qui leur permet de grimper un peu
partout.
Elles ont un poil très épais
pour résister au froid.
Il ne fait pas très chaud ici la nuit.
Et résister également
au rayonnement solaire pendant la journée.
Et puis,
elles ont également de petites mamelles
pour éviter qu'elles ne s'accrochent aux buissons,
aux rochers quand elles gambadent
dans ces reliefs. On continue ?
C'est par où les marmottes ?
Je crois que c'est par là-bas Jamy. Allez je te suis !
Ah ! C'est donc ici qu'habitent les marmottes !
Oui, Jamy, voilà leur secteur.
Elles sont en alerte, tu vois là.
Elles nous regardent.
On peut s'approcher un peu ?
On va s'approcher Jamy. Donc on va avancer doucement.
Je vais sortir la lunette.
Ouais. Donc tu vois Jamy là
on a des marmottes devant nous.
Et tu vois ? Oui oui je l'ai ! Donc c'est une tache, il faut repérer des chamois,
ce sont des taches fauves. Et les plus vieux sont
il connaît le déplacement humain,
il le connaît.
Faut savoir que l’Homme est également un de ses prédateurs.
Mais c'est très curieux également un chamois. Tu vois, il est tout seul,
lui. Souvent, ce sont les mâles qui sont seuls.
Là aussi, c'est un endroit où tu es habitué à les voir.
Oui, on vient très souvent les voir.
Tu vois, c'est une réserve de chasse ici.
Donc on ne chasse pas le chamois ici.
En général, ce sont des animaux
qui sortent le matin. Au lever de soleil,
parce que le but de la journée,
c'est quand même d'aller manger. C'est un ruminant, le chamois également.
C'est une panse.
Une fois que la panse est pleine, il va se coucher soit
à un abri ou soit un rocher.
Il aime bien l'ombre quand même.
Il n'aime pas trop trop les fortes chaleurs, le soleil.
Donc il va se coucher et il rumine.
J'espère que la balade vous a plu
et qu'elle va vous donner des idées
pour amener vos élèves en classe
découverte ici dans le Chablais,
ou vous retrouverez Jean-Paul ou dans d'autres secteurs de la région
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes, que ce soit la Vanoise, la Maurienne,
la Tarentaise, les Bauges, la Chartreuse,
le Vercors, les Aravis ou l'Auvergne.
Tous ces massifs recèlent de trésors.
Sachez que de mon côté,
ça a été un réel bonheur
de vous accompagner dans les différents épisodes de cette classe
grandeur nature, sur des sentiers qui, en automne
comme en hiver, ne sont battus
que par le soleil, le vent et la neige,
que ce soit dans les Alpes ou en Auvergne.
A bientôt !
Et n'oubliez pas la montagne, c'est la classe...
Grandeur nature !